hello and welcome to this well this
podcast we have a name yet I just I just
wanted an excuse to talk about some
anime with a few cool peeps so whatever
will well named is put our podcast in
post but with me today is holding four
important reviews I meant Holden
Casanova and in bro yeah [ __ ] already
got some over I thought we did forgot
yeah it's all good so I say it's Jean
from X's 13 now if it story back Third
Way today that's that's when we're
recording oh are you from animate
appraisal hi guys
we throwback Thursday well then we also
have Joey mystery anime oh wait that's
what you are a throwback that's a sort
of like no one wants us to be proactive
we have a Joey aka the anime man lol oh
my god and we got a key from I don't
know give you just a key [ __ ] parent
a [ __ ] dare um yeah so thank you very
much for joining us today anyways yeah
so how many time zones do we yeah we
weren't we got three different time
zones yeah three different three totally
different time zones because I think
yeah difference between us the third
okay so it what day is it
what are you go I think though with
we're still the same day which I which
is what I made sure you guys just needed
to wake up extra [ __ ] early and
they're recording in the night time okay
and for once now that I'm in the middle
I get to recorder at a reasonable time
you must love it yeah I love it
so yeah the original reason I wanted to
bring everyone together was because
obviously the new season started but
there was one show in particular that
sparked this off and it was when gene
just happened to shoot me a message okay
so hey god I just really really want to
talk to someone about our new Lord and
Savior era manga sensei
it is the future is here Omega is here
continue you wanted to talk you want to
talk to us so what what what did you
want to say about there first of all
okay
all right I feel maybe a little wrong
saying this but I've never had a waifu
before oh I think I have a [ __ ] right
job oh my god Audrey please a kini yes
oh my god why not rest in peace ian has
a [ __ ] moejisha
motor wifey now oh my god I hear ya Joe
you watch you watch an episode of it
then you what sir yeah what were your
first impressions of it I mean you know
what was I expecting from an anime where
the first word they uttered was immortal
first word of the first episode but
anymore darling well I just came in to
exactly what I was expecting to come in
- yeah did you enjoy the rise in the
same light novel writer as the guy who
wrote Oreimo if I remember correctly and
you can definitely see that because I
think like my both meant to be set in
the same universe but I will say like I
went into the show just like ready to
just like hate it you know I went into
where being like this is absolute
garbage perfect mind set to enter
entertainment yeah I saw what happened
I'm sure hey so yeah I would like this I
saw all the [ __ ] gifts and everyone's
like oh so greens were super ugly hey
whatever I'm the fun I'm the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] scene in the second episode
where she's blindfolded not valid in the
fictive say but there's a scene in the
second episode where there's this like
12-yard go saying like [ __ ] I loved
it oh yeah oh yeah yeah everyone seemed
likely yeah yeah yeah it's like Oh a
chin chin you know it's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] filthy Frank just like Amy I'm
gonna write this character but that
sounds like that was all I knew about
the show and I was like this is gonna be
awful this is gonna be trash and I
watched it and it was absolute trash but
I [ __ ] it I just I just
enjoyed myself sorry mark it's one of
those anime that it's like you can't
look away from you just need to continue
to just bask in how bad it is and
everything that's bad about it yeah but
I don't know it's just it's just um it's
just like this perfect car crash of like
the worst the worst things you can find
in an anime like you have one car crash
you'd never seem to see in person
exactly exactly you go on the [ __ ]
team also little sister you got all this
fanservice you got there's go who
[ __ ] apparently likes dick and it's
lollies and it's [ __ ] it like if I if
I talk about this show yeah if I shall
talk about this show in public I'd get
like the weirdest [ __ ] life may be
known as like I think isn't super
forever yeah exactly
I mean I mean Jean are you enjoying it
like honest honest to god I'm absolutely
loving it and I'm loving it so much more
than I liked or II emo like you know
when we had that talk about or email
back know I know and I remember when I
was yes I was like I liked it but there
was nothing that I don't know like I
just didn't see the hype that you guys
saw on it I just I just watched it it
was like okay it's a satisfactory show
like it's good but this is like actually
grabbing my attention it's I'm just so
like hooked in this story and a part of
me doesn't really know why either but
like I just can't look away it's just
like lollies every I think about the
lolly I mean it could be the whole East
but it's just weird for me because I
mean I've seen a lot anime stm-1 [ __ ]
fanservice and itchiness so why do I
like why do I like you know I'm a little
girl I know I like I I don't know either
and I think it's like wrong like this
this is the kind of show where like you
know if you watch it and you kind of
enjoy it you know that you're way too
deep into anime know you're like going
down like you you are going to hell and
like if you if you don't have an
appreciation or not not even an
appreciation just like knowledge of like
some of like the weird of things in
anime like you'd obviously you think
this is weird but for some reason it
just it's it's it's not it's not exactly
a satire but it's just relishing in the
worst
of anime yeah to me that's why I find it
so entertaining I mean Aki and Joey are
you are you guys enjoying it or are you
guys having the opposite effects I know
no god no I hate it hahaha you just
probably just prefer I'd really like
okay hi I read I read the the summary on
this and I wasn't going to be confident
in this at all then from what I've seen
in the gifts it looks just as bad in
this not war so what I'm expecting
it might it might have to be though
because like I also like equally just
like Auriemma
yeah so maybe agree that another I
[ __ ] love Doraemon yeah and NO manga
since there's literally just an audible
reskin so it's like it's more emo but
just even trashy and I didn't think that
was possible
I did not yeah exactly right
even from this episode one I was just
like wow this puts like the ending of
podium you know into a shame well you
know what's sad about this is this is
probably going to be very big in Japan
of course it is yeah man it's not big
already in Japan yeah actually it kinda
already is I mean or am i was [ __ ]
massive in Japan wasn't it yeah I feel
like the main difference between them
though is just like even though the
scenario is just about the same it would
be like the little sisters themselves
like you go from Cuttino who is like an
otaku it was like and I'm not a model
outgoing she woke entire day was the
Buddha ray right and then you go to like
CJD
which is like just my type of girl the
complete opposite I'm not a fan of
students raised by the way like I love
to raise yeah would you like look Sydney
it's the only scene dry for me like I
just do not like stand raise I don't
know there's something about them just I
don't see it acceptance
I don't mind send it is like it just
depends on like how they're like written
and her are just know like I don't know
I just feel like that I mean that like
sometimes it just makes me want to like
hit them and then other times it's just
like oh I can kind of see why they're
kind of stuck up like this yes it's like
it's like a difference between like
basic sins raised like ah stuff and sort
out some line or something which is just
like oh which sin did it for the sake of
sin did it yeah it's in the right for
the sake of cinder a um and then there's
like I mean I mean I'd say I mean I do
like Hironobu I can
see why people hate her because she is
kind of a [ __ ] and really bratty but
yeah but like you get to like the next
level where it's like they actually have
some depth behind them and you know you
look at things like Santa Clara or Oscar
who you know there are still [ __ ] but
they have a bit more deaths behind them
and I can get that character but then I
there's a lot of characters any-any
dairies with with a decent amount of
depth I can get behind you know I do
have a preference to send race or any
any any dairies with a sake of being
just that kind of character
yeah exactly you know you the characters
are basically made to appeal just to
help with the plot yeah exactly been
this story basically to help - help -
help feed that finish answer yeah yeah
yeah I wouldn't even see you feeding the
plot just say yeah just the fetish just
the fact that you know I look new new
girls I'm into young there is oh I like
this anyway because there's a young
there and I guess it's just like the
market really wants to feed off of best
girls I have honor to John Dre's like I
still I still do not understand most
like I don't always like all the dairies
but I understand their appeal I still to
this day like I can't understand you
Andres I just I just can't I can't
understand people who are like I want a
young dairy for a girlfriend I'm like so
you have suicidal tendencies no yeah you
want to I'm not a psychopath as a
girlfriend yeah I want to die oh you
want to be like manipulated and
controlled and possibly sad in your
sleep
yeah I didn't really know how big like
the demand was for your honor ativ even
like like a fetish sort of thing yeah
until you know I just kept seeing people
like saying oh man I would want like the
perfect yandere girlfriend but you know
the whole concept of that kind of
relationship isn't really done well I
mean but I still have like it's like
they wander they want a submissive yeah
well I can still like like yandere
characters I mean obviously I don't like
them in the concept of like fetish
budget well Risa keiondre yeah well like
I'm almost gone in the thing that like I
don't mind the dare is as long as
there's like some kind of depth or like
some kind of reminder yeah like hiatus
from shuffle
yeah looking fantastic yeah step that's
like a young dairy that like makes sense
Rebecca yeah throw back there sorry back
those bags well as that whole done
Claire from Baccano was my favorite
yandere oh yeah yeah she's right yeah
she's the mute girl
I don't know how yeah that's pretty
weird here you go watch [ __ ] oh now
forget of the season at you then watch
this is a pretty good season it's not
you pretty good to see but again this
season yeah let's just talk about Bach
gonna talk about [ __ ] oh no oh my god
when I get into it so how long have you
known me Jeana how long have I been just
telling you to go watch [ __ ] yeah it's
only 12 episode 7 and I am seven and
half years yeah
[Music]
one is now I don't know for like going
back to era manga sensei I guess the
best and worst thing about it is that it
takes all the tropes you see or like the
shallow throat you see that you see in
these like otaku bating like shows
especially enlightened light novel shows
that we see a lot these days like you
have a ton of them every season and I
mean they mostly now they have really
stupid long last names which I don't
know what I don't know why that because
all those just getting lazy with making
creative titles yeah but it's just uh
IRA Munger sensei just appeals like the
trash side of me and there is a trash
side of me yeah you like the big orders
everybody has a trash yeah everyone has
a trash side there's no change
how does that whole like guilty-pleasure
anime you know like everyone everyone
has like a just if you look at it as a
reviewer it's just the worst anime you
could imagine but it's like you know
what I still watch this I mean does it
it gets me through a good day
I mean I mean I mean the best the best
way to get to know someone is when you
when you learn what their trash side is
because yeah Eddie I reminds me of uh
Joey when we met for the first time in
Akihabara perfect place for me the
perfect place to me the only plan to me
and so like I feel like the [ __ ] the
first thing he takes me to is like you
your typical like anime shop you know
your supply - we go through these floors
and floors of just figuring into
whatever ways you know standard anime
stuff I like literally the second place
to take him to you any he's like so guys
do you want to go to a dojinshi store
and I was like my [ __ ] man why did
let's go
yeah dude Stokes mother I've been down
there I can't like ya wanna do is I said
no yeah hell yeah there's like no faster
way to bond with someone going through
seven [ __ ] stories of anime porn is
thunder are you actually my first time
going through like all of those for like
I'm guessing you guys at one point when
to animate sure yeah yeah okay yeah like
there was it seems like you know at
first it's like a dream come true when
you see all these figures but the first
time they're silly it's so overwhelming
to the point it's like busy but I mean
no but I like the I like the system that
they have also in anime where because
there's so much they require you to like
write on a card of what box and what
number oh yeah yeah yeah
so like super useful to have yeah
because it's like I remember going south
going it was just like the my my biggest
exposure to this much anime merchandise
was in like an anime corn or something
like that and anime was just like 7
floors of the dealer's room stacked on
top of each other and it was a very
[ __ ] overwhelming but I find out like
it goes underground yeah you can go like
the smaller stores and it's just like oh
there's literally seven floors of this
and it goes on the ground as well and
you're just like oh my [ __ ] go and
that's just one demo one building that
moment you realize you're walking
through the street through the normal
streets of Akihabara knowing that you're
walking over five floors of porn under
you feeling that it's a great feeling
Holden have you been watching anything
this season yeah yeah I've been watching
Shing a scene of a haunting soul dude oh
dude yeah it was on prime affiliate link
in the description below
oh no inside Adam a Adam a strike now
isn't yeah yeah man what do you think of
the second season which injecting the
Bahaman and it's it's like you expect it
to not be great because you're like well
it can't be as good as the first one
I've been burned so many times where
like see unnecessary sequels and it's
right
the coolest thing about is it's it's
super cool because it's not about any of
the main characters from the first
season it's just about the world they
lived in right and it's super cool
because the environment was probably the
strongest part about and get you know
behind all those years ago yeah I mean I
never actually finished the first season
of shingeki no Bahamut I really do but I
from for one I remember it was pretty
pretty [ __ ] dope man it looks great
it was wise to get matha
yeah yeah I'm enjoying them a lot like
yeah that's like you're a nice man yeah
finish up the yeah heavy animation how
do you Yasim with that yeah do we lose
the baby
oh man girl we get up big strange gay
[ __ ] dude I'm - movie of the year man
don't worry can we get a kid wait we're
getting we're getting movie yeah yeah
yeah you're a nice movie man oh cool
Joey like when we were going through
when we're going through the merch store
and we saw like the like walls still to
be realized she's like can I burn that
pillow as Victor and I'd be a dude it'd
be URI on fire yeah fire me tonight
Harry on fire oh my god I can't even
imagine it cuz whenever I was there it
was like like there was no huge you know
female-oriented show I was coming out at
all I think that maybe the clothes not
really now did it's like completely
changing like the last couple years
thanks to like you know like you're a
nice I'm like hike you look great I was
there it was the the Kuroko no Basuke
was still in full swing was when I lived
there and so like the curl up and
everything was going on in like a mock
our best day and everything so I can you
imagine I ever felt so yeah because a
lot of desert for that one yeah but it's
like I can't imagine what you're a nice
must be like then because it's it's such
a phenomenon in that regard well it is
as big as it got here in the west of
like if [ __ ] like blew up here anyway
I mean yeah it was it was huge
like it's still big like the fact that
like it's becoming a movie so quickly
like this knows how big it is
yeah and there was a what else what else
I think I went to a dojin store and then
like you were looking so forward to it
again because you know you're going to
show you were going to show our friends
that we brought there yet because you
know that's just kind of a tradition but
then you walk in there and you see it's
literally mostly Yuri ah nice
it's like shelves and shelves of you're
in Japan they'll milk out like the most
popular anime like everywhere until you
can't milk it out and right so you
probably get so sick of it
just seeing all the advertiser looking
at you literally every Idol show I do
like Loveline and Idol master is like
everywhere ever and I do not get that
every train station I walk in I walk
into any like store in Asia because it's
not just Japan it's like all over Asia
walking to any anime store and they have
like walls and walls just love live and
Idol master money oh it's my first
thoughts like I so this is what hell
looks like you probably saw like all
just by seeing all the advertisements
and [ __ ] like I don't yeah I I know most
of the girls and I don't think I've ever
seen I don't know I've never actually
finished a love life or a mystery but I
know most of them yeah in the end the
only thing like love level Idol master
related that I've been exposed to other
diligence because they're actually
ignored of course is like Jeff Macke
ethnic oh [ __ ] never shows like by day
they call me the anime man by night
I am the hentai do the anti mascot okay
like it's alter-ego anime man by Jerry
Johnny the hentai kid dude that's like
that's my name by night today go legit
are you enjoying urine I since like if
you are just getting back into anime
nothing yeah I actually I like the hype
I guess so you're going into it more
blind than everybody else you said
anyway yeah I miss the [ __ ] crunch ro
anime Awards
exactly ya know when we did our previous
podcast about it I don't know if what
you guys are talking about
don't like stay quiet I didn't know
anything about it but she why I don't
like lesbians
laughs so what's okay that's what's your
perspective event like coming into this
blind then without all the hype that
we've had to go through um well I did
enjoy it a lot like I I had to keep
watching it it was like one of those
shows that episode and I'm like okay
next episode and like I was so happy I
could do that because I didn't have to
wait menu out of breath to do so next
week for the next episode to come out
yeah nobody's somebody bad in my
experience now you mentioned in geniu
cuz I had to wait a week and so I I
don't know your your perspective would
probably a lot different then right like
because for the first three weeks right
my perspective of the show was very
different in the last three weeks of the
show yeah the pretty good day kind of
let it flow well it's I'm like Miz it's
gonna be like a Sports Center
yeah I feel like I wasn't wrong yet it's
like I wonder if that's valuable in some
way I guess holy moly that's like you're
taking I quit I'm like oh you're skinny
again I'm rubbing my hands and I'm like
whoo accel world season 2 with ice oh I
don't know like I don't know why I like
doing shooting I was dreaming us you
chubby not to love bully our Cokie no
but I mean I was able to marathon it so
I didn't do it but like after like
towards the end of the series I felt
like I was just watching a repeat of
like every other episode it was like
yeah I mean like oh yeah the same dance
and I just put a new dude in it like
every episode for every competition yeah
like yeah the thing is is like
definitely when it got like halfway
through up to the end it's as if you
were just watching like a real-life like
ice skating competition using items that
you probably don't know an ice skating
now I know when y'all show is thank you
yeah and then and then they uh what is
it they start putting like a lot of
emphasis on like what kind of moves they
did and then the characters like whoa
they try to make a lot of like climactic
scene based off of these moves that you
to a viewer that doesn't know anything
about ice skating they all kind of look
the same Fabiana like
like sometimes when they were doing
their dancing and the way the like the
angle would be you wouldn't see their
hands or their feet I'm like you just
look like they have like no [ __ ]
there's no gravity and they're just like
yeah being [ __ ] is something you'd
be the only one that had a different
type of I would say literally you only
want to have a different type of like
ice skating routine every time he came
on was was like guy that liked pole
dances that like squeezes all that we
didn't do it oh yeah yeah yeah I wanted
our Kristoff yeah Kristoff stuff I know
maybe Kristoff yeah it could be
Christmas I know it's Chris something
it's not GJ style suitcase no jealous
sigh oh god please oh my god he had that
whole song that guy i straight-up could
watch an entire series about just JJ
Styles did that happen his mom it was so
cool
was anyone else expecting to just have a
total like jojo pose during one of those
like yes I mean I did it all the time
doing interviews you would just dad is
what I was expecting
lady I mean I mean I said I think my
biggest wrong with yer nice was that it
wasn't like I went into we're wanting it
to be kind of like a sports anime I
guess and as a sports anime I didn't
really enjoy it that much
obviously there's this other layer I was
only into it for like the romance aspect
but I didn't get [ __ ] from it let you
look let's say real I think like the
people who went into urine eyes
expecting to be a Sports anime it would
wait the 1% yeah well okay like like
like I was like I was super buying into
it I was the first trailer just a piano
solo and everything I was like damn
they're gonna [ __ ] change the game
and [ __ ] again like this looks a good
[ __ ] in here get a second trailer
they're like I'm biting my nails have
like a circus song I'm like oh god I'd
like mine actually these gays I don't
want to be yeah when it comes to sports
anime um with the thing that I liked
about other ones like okay let's just
take like yo mushi pedal for example
they made the sport um like interesting
enough that even though you probably
know nothing about cycling they
explained it in such a way where it were
to the story and it works with like the
struggle of the character trying to ride
up the hill
yeah with Yuri ah nice they kind of just
named off the the moves they showed you
the routine and it wasn't really
anything that really pulled you in if
you knew nothing about their look like
look how cool these characters look like
honorable tow axes yeah I was about to
say xxx
and it was also kind of like them kind
of showing off like the animators of
their ability to even make these scenes
which was impressive that they could do
these but yeah we animation of the year
yeah well it's not the best animation
ever but the style of making ice skating
and the way that they did it I mean yeah
I was impressed but it wasn't enough for
me to really like like grab into the
story like yellow mushi pedal did when
they explained just something as simple
as like the wheel and if like one part
breaks off that's actually a big effing
deal and then they try to like really
bring it home on why that's a big deal
and why that will ruin everything
well I would have preferred yeren s it
feels like I don't know one of the guys
like broke his leg me too routine okay
I'm [ __ ] high thanks yeah I think you
know like during this show I was like I
hope you [ __ ] fall really win or
something
no I mean Michael is catchy but after it
was just repeating itself after a while
I'm like all right I'm not yeah yeah I
got wattages but there wasn't enough
time to develop the characters for us
for me to care enough about their
routines and what their retirement I
think they I think it was just a quick
case of they just try to do too much in
too little time cuz like what drew me in
the first episode was the [ __ ]
animation because if the animation had
stayed that's good like I like I would I
would be I would be like I'll be really
up for this but like they tried to do
like [ __ ] 500 routines every episode
so of course yeah it would have got
boring you know it would have would have
got stale if you just saw like the same
routine if we if they are just space it
out a bit more or how to format well
well it just seemed like their format
was okay keep showing everybody doing
their routine and showing like the
little intricate parts and their inner
thoughts of like their performance when
it's like why can't you just beer off
the other people and maybe show us like
a relationship or romance aspect like
happening all the scenes or something
like that like give
more plot rather just putting us in like
the audience seat in the ice rink the
only the only characters that were
received that were like the borderline
incest couple yeah later so triplets
with the mom ice not sound like a cute
but yeah but yeah so I think I learned
more from ice skating from blades of
glory than I did from the animation -
there's one thing that I noticed but and
I never really noticed this before it I
don't know if anybody else has noticed
this or maybe I'm just [ __ ] crazy but
like Yuri had so many different art
styles like I don't know I felt like
every time his face came on frame like
there was one art style and then like
you would see a different almost like a
different face structure with him and I
don't know why they did really well
that's that's that's just cold bad and I
guess that's that old animation of the
years I was just waiting I don't know I
didn't know like which face to keep like
as him in my head because it's like is
he like like and it's like one episode
he's fat and they're like he doesn't
look fat and like half of the episode
and then he's fat again
it's like yeah act like they don't not
done it yet they don't know whether to
keep him fat alone yeah because it's
like when he was doing the initial lake
dance that what was that dude his
[ __ ] coach what was his name um
Victor no thank you
it was like he didn't look fat there but
he was fat because that was the first
episode so it's like you didn't keep the
proportions right and that's just like
threw me off yeah I think because every
time they like show it off like an ice
skating scene like they had to like be
she Phi it otherwise yeah that's what yo
she is watching with it being like I
don't want to watch some guy so I find
out forces have been as cool it well I
don't know after orange is like clear
change in animation it's been hard to
really compete well we don't talk about
orange well we can I can I can watch
watched or URI on ice is not d'Ivoire
man that's crazy
we could totally talk about oranges we
would
my key card wenches cut in a live-action
film when I was in Japan so long ago
MERS yeah I watch that yeah the funny
life I can adaptations that just appear
and just never leave Japan almost
limbless [ __ ] I mean but with orange
like I just I just couldn't get into the
anime like I read the manga before and I
was super into that but the yawn I the
army which is missing something I know
like did you read the manga before gene
or didn't I just watched the anime what
did you think about that right I did
like it
I mean um it just I kind of just took it
more seriously like man this is about
suicide like this could be a situation
in real life for somebody so it's like a
nice show especially for anybody that's
looking to like and I'm I'll feel better
about themselves
yeah like if you want to kill yourself
please don't kill yourself and watch
orange everybody watching I'm there I'm
sorry I thought it was like I guess the
concept of you know these friends trying
to really help a suicidal friend who
isn't open about themselves I guess he
kind of depicted of someone being
suicide and wanting to cover up his
feelings for the sake of everyone else
yeah he doesn't have to burden them I
thought that that was well done but then
as soon as they get to the part about
about like a weird thing like what a
lock holder I was like what I did I
didn't I just let it but yeah mine did I
just I was like alright [ __ ] best
element I still like them though I had
to I I mean I still like to look at the
concept of you know their future selves
trying to reach out to their younger
selves because not very literally like
it's trying to it's trying to reflect
you know if anyone has lost anyone what
would you have done better back then
yeah or would you have been able to see
them or predict what would have happened
but I guess it's the show itself I mean
I guess that's why I was following it
just to see you know if they would save
Kakadu but but like in that season I
feel real life did that whole thing
better I don't know how a nice
III never what's really so dude like
takes place in college I I thought it's
good that's I'm I heard I'd say I think
it's pretty like I think it's way more
decent than orange in the whole like
what would you do if you could like redo
your life and like change
because like in real life is old I had
like this segment where like the main
character like like the boss like you
know killed herself like off the you
know being harassed at the workplace
because of because he was like - like
backwards thinking like not sticking up
to her and [ __ ] like that and like just
the way like they explored that bit was
like I think it was better done than
orange and also without the you know
whole black hole [ __ ] alright so I'm
going to watch that and then I'll get
back to you in the next time yeah yeah
what if you liked orange I think you'll
everywhere so it was weird because like
what did it was they release all real
life all that was so it was like they
didn't like a Netflix show yeah honey
like the anime community just don't know
how to deal with that because no one
really talked about it because it was
just like ah [ __ ] we have all these
episodes at once but then there's also
everything in the season so I guess I
guess we'll just watch real life later
then once Weaver what's up you know what
yeah no one did yeah and no one did she
just kind of like one which is kind of
what I think is gonna happen with our
little witch academia cuz like well like
rift life oh yeah
yes little wish Govinda also the devil
man cry baby as well bye which was
announced with my Netflix is acquisition
and a their deal with Scott who is Oh
doc you I yeah it's like he was
meditation of the moment basically any
anime like just is licensed by Netflix
as well I'm looking forward to blame I'm
look I'm super looking for yeah I'm
creating myself I'm looking right she's
a bear dude to bear with the aka it's
going to be gripping like trading myself
for blame because I've been watching
Kato
oh you're watching obviously Isaac's
hiding now ah Jesus also I'd you
specifically I think you'd specifically
as a person like it knowing you I very
so realizing I didn't get it on it yeah
Arjun is awesome I'm like a super huge
fan of the modulate well like like when
I saw the animals like oh god 3G 3d bleh
once you get past the whole 3d aspect of
it's like it's super well yeah pictures
man dude they're proving is the big
thing
my problem with Arjun because I watch
almost the first season was just I just
I just had the main character to seems
so off you know what I mean cuz like oh
yeah he like kind of disappears how much
not really a character feels like yeah
cuz it's just like you know like I was
trying to like understand his thought
process but it was just so weird and out
there I mean at first he was you think
he's just like this kind of sociopaths
and then he he shows like some
compassion and then he goes back to just
being this kind of robotic kind of
character and I was just like I really
couldn't wrap my head and have my head
around him and I guess that was like my
only big thing that stopped me from just
marathoning the whole thing cuz I did I
did really like Arjun 3d aside I don't
want to get into another 3d debate piece
Bruce Boche totally talking about 3d
there's one show this season that I
didn't include in my seasonal video what
I think is actually one of the best and
that is a [ __ ] out flow is it cut
okay yeah Kato cut right answer the
right song so yeah oh my god have you
ever seen a jean yeah I just caught up
with it last night man I've been going
I'm gonna go easy with anime that sounds
like yeah man
man I've been I'm going crazy and loving
it okay so for those who don't know what
K knows about it basically it's kind of
like it's kind of like a first contact
scenario where you have this alien that
has landed on earth and it's more of a
show about how you'd go about like
communicating with alien and what it
turns into is actually a very very
interesting thought experiment
yeah it's and that's what I was gonna
say too because like it's 3d or CG and
it's like yeah doesn't bother you
because they're just talking the dream
though dude it's Fire Emblem CG man fire
em Lucy G I was so excited CG that
doesn't bother you but what I wear
because what what holds the show up if
it's writing which is yeah it's like it
starts off in the first concept but then
it turns to this weird thought
experiment of okay if and I'm not going
to spoil a specific plot details
if an if an alien landed on earth and
gave humanity this far-out technology
that could advance the human race like
by [ __ ] millennia
right if we had this technology in our
hands what would we do with it and how
would we go about even improving
humanity are we even ready for it
because it's just like what happens is
the alien gives us piece of technology
and the humans ask why are you here and
it's the endings just like I just want
to improve the human race here have this
technology and then we're just like holy
[ __ ] yeah we do with it it's like a myth
control and powers now yeah
the technology can easily be used for
good but can also be used for weapons
which could easily wipe out the human
race and you guess the thinking man
humans are just pretty [ __ ] stupid
yeah thank you well I want you to take
it and just you yeah where's this hard
just to like dominate from the alias
perspective it's just like why can't you
just use this to improve humanity I'm
literally just giving this to you out of
the goodness of my heart and the humans
just like what the [ __ ] how do we even
manage this is your fault of them like
but now I'm given a dish for like
they're making the United States look
like [ __ ] that really I enjoy that
you like yeah I just feel like [ __ ] when
I see that well [ __ ] very much it's Anna
that's like a [ __ ] gate where the way
I just yeah when you know I say she's
the bad guy yeah yeah I always find that
hilarious it's just for taking your home
from us but I like shadow the right
answer is definitely an underrated
series which I recommend anyone pick up
the season because not many people are
talking about I mean I didn't even watch
it before I released my spring video and
was just like everyone's just like oh
you missed out kado admittedly I skipped
it because it was 3d yeah like it really
doesn't bother you because it's more
about like the story and the plot more
than anything there's not even like much
movement or action I do yeah I like it
yeah it really doesn't yeah it looks
good I mean you only notice it when
they're walking I can't so though we're
just like have many of you seen sukiyaki
day which is airing this season yeah I
actually have them yeah oh my god
I was getting real says those
but it would okay well I'm like I don't
know it I don't even know has anyone uh
started a clockwork yeah um okay I said
okay I stopped up I can't have one I
stopped us dude no ah okay
I almost listen I watched it last night
sir nice wonderful all right so I saw
the first episode last night and like
five minutes in the kids like I guess
like that [ __ ] coffee and like book
through the roof and like his clock
broke and he's like my switch loved us
I'm I did copy ladder that son is like a
Little John lyric I don't know why have
to see it I've all the focus in the room
know and I can see he's talking about
his clocks of lovers like utter Oh after
hand shakers I can see that the
animators really just want like really
want an excuse to really use that like
3d animation of what is like first the
chains and now they're using it with the
clocks um but ya know with clockwork
planet like there was a lot of hype on
it mainly I guess it was this because it
was from you Kamiya again and then they
were expecting someone something just as
like aesthetically pleasing and with
like a story like no game no life but
like with this one i I don't really know
what the hell happened the first one so
much information was given at the st. at
the same time and they made everything
about clocks and there wasn't really a
point to any of the clock so I'd walk
work I mean huh I roll out my episodes
oh no of one and a half okay I'm a
gliding mother like myself I feel like
the COO like I haven't read a clock or
planet yet but from what I saw in the
animation I feel like the clocks are
just there to kind of just make
something pretty for the end and there's
to work on yeah this for something for
them to work on also a lot of people
were expecting like you know lots of
bright vivid colors from you call me
again but with I think no game no life
Alan is given by madhouse and this one's
given to what is it
oh yes yeah yeah and you know I think
that I realized that like just because
of just because of the come you you like
Noble that doesn't mean the artisans
going to be the same yeah and well also
what was one thing this is weirdly
turned quickly into of sailing harem
yeah I have the first up yeah yeah the
only anime from Xebec that they're
really famous for are apparently harem
which is to revenue and loving over
immense weight was the bezel where to
carry multi mega ma- yeah no I was no no
I wasn't a of loving I was thinking of
cage oh they did change okay today Joe
as well that's weird yeah this weird
that you said was like seebik for me or
sub X sorry I only take a foam Allah
panic and broken blade like I only think
of mecca's when I hear sub ik so I know
that the making format to panic will
start surgery let me handle the first
two they made one other no no no Gong do
you think your studio gonzo which made
made the first one okay then I guess I'm
just sticking of broken bleep but I
thought is it okay apologies to economy
effect who's probably listening to there
something like Oh Studios they mean
anything but um yeah we've clockwork
planets the big red flag for me was a
[ __ ] finger blow - weed which is a
mouth [ __ ] nowhere oh my god yeah
yeah I don't like that those a bit those
valves the big red cycle yet always
exposition oh yeah then you were just
like what was going on and then out of
nowhere this girl was just like sucking
off a finger
yeah and I was just like oh I really
pause the show and I thought to myself
do I want to stop now or try to finish
the episode I said well can i why but
I'm moving on from what's on the season
has anyone been watching the big ones
like attack on time season - yeah
lately I feel like so many people are
talking about attack on Titan like
attack on Titan has just spread like
wildfire like everywhere I mean they did
wait a long time I think less people are
talking about taco inside season 2 then
obviously like the height died down a
[ __ ] ton compared to what it was four
years ago
yeah I think I think like the way it was
so long they're like people just like
[ __ ] I'm gonna read them like I've
talked to a lot of people who were like
super super into attack on Titan you
know that the second season is airing
but they just they might be waiting yeah
they just haven't watched y'all they
just seem like as well yeah yeah what's
your but we also remember like it's been
attack of Titan
came out like four years ago and I guess
they dubbed it so like a lot more
viewers especially we're here on the
west probably watching like the dubbed
version so they probably don't know of
the second seasons existence yet until
they see it in stores or something yeah
cuz I guess attackers I can just break
all kinds of [ __ ] mainstream barriers
they had a lot of time to do I mean I
just I just think they I don't know why
they had to wait four years to to get on
this [ __ ] train again because I feel
like they've missed a lot by waiting
four years I think it was just a hard
production and they come in 25 over so
it just takes like you know it could
take almost two and a half years to make
that oh I thought it was only 12 episode
oh this is nutty around you have the
original one I guess that's true I'm
trying to get back on the Carbonari
train as well I mean just the tree yeah
no pun intended
um yeah I guess like I guess Mike my
quick thoughts on the second season of
what I've watched so far it's very very
different from the first season like
anyone it's really somatically different
yeah not actually show anyone yeah it's
not an action show anymore there's like
it's so far there's a mystery show that
has action and it's a missing arrow show
which is like Titans are [ __ ] scary
again which is great if you remember if
you remember that feeling you had when
you watch the very very first episode
for the very first time
no microwave hands yes Michael knows
just as ridiculous Hawaii Kyojin but
today the Titans are more lethal they're
not like before they were just like you
know playing Super Smash Brothers and
hitting the dummy bag like the practice
racer you know they're just obstacles in
the way for Captain Levi to go human
blood yeah yeah
whereas now they're like lethal again
one Titan can potentially kill somebody
and it's just honor it wasn't like that
before yeah unless they were just trying
to be like what we got to kill everybody
yeah but genuinely scary and there's
this mystery aspect which was never
prevalent in attack on Titan anymore
because you know every which all the
wall of division until the wall other
variable until literally just the walls
of crap yeah I'm a Titan oh my god I'm
all went to [ __ ] like II thought she got
me thinking because I'm actually
enjoying the second season a lot more
than I enjoyed the first season yeah me
too well you both know like how I am
about life characters going into like
gigs question of like why it probably
took so long I mean I heard one because
the animators were being paid really
badly so like a lot like pulled out for
some reason but and I guess he didn't
have enough but I don't know how
effective that was towards the anime but
another one was where the anime left off
in season 1 I heard it was extremely
close to where the manga was caught up
with and I guess he wanted to make the
manga so far ahead right in order for it
not so that they would have a lot of
material to work with yeah for the anime
because I guess he had a choice of
whether to I think I made a video on
this one like saying that he had a
choice of he can either just make them
both at the same time or if like the
anime goes ahead you can probably just
improvise or he spends more time on the
manga and waits it out and then has
something to give out to the fans of
attack on Titan not to mention he made
that mom to come out monthly instead of
weekly yeah we have to consider four
years is like you know four times 12
you're going to write a whole while a
it's 48 chapters which is basically yeah
little like that it currently is yeah
right so maybe it was also like in a mix
with like I guess other liked echoes
technical stuff with the staff but they
also worked on carbon Eddie which is
weird
but what was I going to say with this
even though I've heard I've read the arc
already and I do like what I forgot who
said it earlier that they're making
Titan scary again and yeah yeah and I
guess like from this point on for a
little bit this is more of like trying
to reveal like now everything that the
Titans are and in consciousness to like
the the hidden I guess what is the goal
behind what they're trying to do and I
use my mind at all yeah yeah just all
really asking long and I was a fantastic
video but ya know I it's kind of funny
because like Joey and I we were also
thinking at the same time when we were
watching this anime when you know who's
who then you start saying like oh yeah I
know why you look in the way yeah I was
like ah episode 1 because like I've
already like caught I'm pretty much like
caught up to the manga like monthly
right and so I like when I saw episode 1
I was like man I wonder what would
happen if I just win on Twitter right
now and I just gave spoilers like well
thank you like how many people would
want to like kill me I think they're all
I think another reason why that like you
know this art isn't so much action is
because you know they already gave us so
much in the first season this is the
time when the story itself is now
supposed to unfold
um I mean so you know but I still like
it and I like that not a lot of you know
from animation stuff didn't change even
though we waited so long I feel like I
could easily smoothen like if I were to
start season 1 again I could easily just
move into season 2 and it looks like you
looked exactly the same
which is something I tried it's only
season two's like changed like our
Styles like like subtly in like say
something like heresy or something like
that where the first season looks very
different from the second season where
they try to like Keanu Phi or the
character designs yeah but for me with
this being only 12 episodes do you think
they are going to announce another
season applies in in the last episodes I
feel like that's like a trend that's
just hiring now I was about so that's
exactly what I think is going to happen
I mean there be stupid not you're just
kind of like but it's just kind of like
the format now I think the 2017 it's
just not I don't think that you should
air to [ __ ] because you can you can
cover an entire year if you air every
other season like if you think of it
that way yeah you cover more relevance
that way then if you do it all
sequentially because then you get to
restart again with another first episode
and that kind of incentivizes people to
you know potentially go back or catch up
where's my I see episode 15 has been
released of a show unlike [ __ ] I miss
that tray and like I'm I can't what if
you see episode 1 I would mocha no hero
academia for instance that revitalized
my interest to go back and watch season
long and finish at this nycos as a
[ __ ] talking about just gonna just
gonna
I live for taught about what I'm trying
to think of another anime I've seen the
season I saw just like the first episode
of Alice's otaku because when I saw the
when I saw the summary I thought it was
kind of interesting to have an old man
as the bag really surprised me and then
I've really enjoyed the what attitude
selector yeah I yeah I love that first
episode
yeah and uh you know the relation I
thought it would been really interesting
to what when I saw that you know it was
supernatural also and then he has like
he grows like a weird I guess or it's
not weird just a relationship with like
a little girl so I guess like that kind
of like brought me in at first that
first episode though at first I was
wondering why it was going for so long I
didn't realize oh yeah I didn't realize
it was a double episode as well yeah
like I I told myself I said I'm either
getting really into this or
this is really like oh crap 45 minutes
so the thing about because I didn't read
the synopsis
I just went in literally just looking at
the cover which is just like
if your guy in Alice and it was just
like oh this is probably going to be
like a slice of life of an old guy
inside yeah let's just not talk okay
like I just found out how the [ __ ]
mug yeah
oh my garden you saw I have it have you
read the manga Jean no it's in a crate
in my basement it's in my basement
oh hell yeah when you read when you read
the manga and finish it we gotta talk
about I uh pretty much what the manga
carry on from where the anime ended so I
heard a little bit so I bought yeah I'll
let you know when I get to that but yeah
um that's what I thought the show was
going to be like that kind of show
so when we add this Liana like elfin
leave style escape like suck in little
girls experimenting on beginning I was
like what what the [ __ ] is this there's
like why is there a girl literally
floating on a giant [ __ ] titan arms
like I said this is definitely not what
I expected it to be and that it was that
element that kind of that I've got
blending of the old man slice-of-life
element with the supernatural element I
really really enjoyed but I really
really hated the CG the CG was goddamn
awful in them
oh yeah with the car with the car the
[ __ ] wrecking ball yeah that was
super weird yeah it came in like a giant
[ __ ] wrecking ball chasing this takes
as many I just look like the worst
[ __ ] ps2 game of all [ __ ] time but
ya know like you know just like with
Clockwork Orange like you know what
those little animation 1980s masters I
see also love Stanley Kubrick winning
yeah Alan kearbey just use a [ __ ] see
jeez
yeah we're always in 2001 Space Odyssey
so [ __ ] funny - but you went from
[ __ ] big [ __ ] go blue clock one
girl [ __ ] is what the [ __ ] happens
yeah so those little things like what
they did at Alice's otaku and then like
just the unnecessary like
just Oh like over-the-top very detailed
animation that they've been trying to do
is just an excuse for them to try out
something new oh I don't know if they'll
be utilizing any of those in like some
good anime yeah but yeah no I thought
I'm just being no that was awesome
savage awesome okay oh yeah speaking of
uh what are some like good anime that I
really liked I saw I really really did
like this isn't from spring but March
comes in like a lion that's the first
anime it's so weird that's the first
anime I teared up at I have never tried
well actually I got a boy so cool so
good yeah the only the only other enemy
of cried out was monster rancher only
because it ended I know right we talked
about this laughs like on our own
podcast laughing and she's like I cried
watching monster rancher and like I
didn't grow up with us I looked it up
and I'm like you cried out briefly
yellow eyeball do you know just briefly
as my brief reason is because that was
the first time where I finished an anime
journey from beginning to end so that
was like a lot for me to take in and I
was like what like I don't know seven at
the time so it wasn't like a huge light
you know Shonen thing where you like
watch like 300 episodes it was a regular
I forgot how many episodes it was but it
felt like it was 300 because the journey
was just so long for me but yeah I know
that was the only reason but March comes
in like a lion I teared up bad because I
guess is well one there it's really
interesting seeing the concept that
they're taking a guy who who is
successful who wins all the time but
he's depressed of well I'm not going to
give any spoilers of like his past or
anything but one big reason is because
he finds it his success to be the burden
of other people and he sees the pain
that he's kind of causing the loser yeah
and so the I guess so especially by
episode 10 where he is like yelling at
like the sky or yelling at you know the
people that he wishes he could yell at
saying you're not trying hard enough
it's not
my fault you're losing but deep down he
still blames himself that like I could
easily just lose on purpose just to make
them feel better but he has his own
pride to take care of but it's like kind
of killing him on the inside and I
really loved it and it was also
interesting to see so many big names
that oh she just saw a cutout um to
guard but it it was so cool to see that
there were so many big names that
support that's not like production wise
but just like they loved it so much like
the guy who made berserk he made that
like little card at the end of episode
one and then yeah instead of writing
more desert yeah this is this boy does I
just cameos himself you know he was
himself instead of writing whatever
that's what he's been doing this whole
time he's like I'm gonna make cards for
this no March comes in like lion was
fantastic also I like a bump of chicken
who did the open other's eyes they may
be opening a year before man that was
well in the ending see what was actually
yeah yeah it became the ending they made
it was cool how that worked out they
they made that because they loved the
manga and then them yeah and the manga
artists came to them I mean one thing I
really liked but also cool the opening
are both absolutely incredible also yeah
one thing I liked about much like lush
it's just so well directed there are
some things I just brilliant and it's
just it's you know off that there's
absolutely very best because it's still
the video style still looks very shaft
but it uses it in a way to enhance the
scene rather than just being like oh
look at this it's short animation with
shaft art ah but the thing I like it's
another Yuki symbol direction right um
probably but it could be the obligatory
but who directs chef yes
while stage of course yeah the chief
director there's a lot of individual
moving parts to something like that yeah
yeah yeah it's still super surprising
coming from the studio that brought
Unisa coin did they bring you yeah
something like this yeah I mean he's
like oh it was definitely an animated
was that was just like it was just a
shot visuals where I was just like I
don't really see the point for fun is
the five Instagram
filter to nice away and I was what
Nisekoi was it could have just as easily
been done by a one-way traffic yeah baby
probably wouldn't want it we just Shep
like we're taking it we're putting
Instagram filter out it yeah what was
that oh yeah speaking of some Studios
that like are kind of weird uh and one
is that new one that madhouse just kind
of created out of nowhere for one anime
and that's studio nut nice house isn't
that you have to talk about you do your
net did you get yeah has anyone uh
finished or watched oh you're just
thinking did of course yeah it's um it's
pretty edgy dude if they G is [ __ ] on
yeah D uh she's a really strong
character but I feel like she's putting
like such like an on not a very good I
guess not as an equal
leveled story as for someone as crazy as
her oh good put it in a nut well the
thing is like what were they good cuz
like I feel like iik so I like it
professional anime youtuber here I
didn't watch any shows from LA season
just coming on out so like nothing
really stood out for me
aside from everyone talking about may
Dragon arcus I guess I have to say it or
because we're gonna crucify me yeah acha
13 is so good man archive just like an
older the anime so good dude how do they
do it man tax auditing how do they do it
I don't get it it's it's just them
adapting super smart source material as
like as good as they can I still haven't
seen it but I need to know you say that
I think I think Kobayashi is dragon made
was like a nice refreshing in the life
of the life of slice slice what life
like a life like genre but to be honest
I think one place of life that I still
put above that as of recently as a
sweetness and lightning which was
definitely very old oh I love that I
haven't heard of that yeah so I I'm
hashtag daughter go yeah that daughter
was just absolutely fantastic and I I
really breaks your heart like when you
know this is a scene in anime
or any anyone out there will want to
know like if they want to watch this or
anything but going from like the dad's
perspective of seeing like he wants to
play both the father and the replacement
of the mother and not trying to explain
things to the daughter and trying to
like just use culinary as a way for
moving on I really loved that concept of
the anime like even though in every
single episode it's just it's kind of
like the same routine it's just a new a
new type of food yeah you see how much
it means to them because it's stuff that
the mom made and it's a way for them to
both bond together as father and
daughter but also to remember their the
things that their mother had done for
them and then that episode 9 oh my god
when she starts crying when she knows
oh man that broke my eye I saw psychosis
yeah I hope that voice actress of the
little girl just never grows up because
she has the most important but she
voices the little sister in a silent
voice as well and [ __ ] every time Wow
every time she opens the mouth is just
like like I don't care about my way but
like every time she opens her mouth I
get it it's just like oh I don't know
what's your heart rate would sue McGee's
voice like I think the little touch that
really sold me about her voice is the
little list yeah that she's that she
does she's like oh gosh Aang yeah like I
thought that was so cute yes that anime
was so [ __ ] good like and I was just
like going around crunchyroll and I just
saw that I was like oh this might be
good and I'm hungry and I just ended
food or so then I the I'm and I what I
went in there and then I was like oh man
I'm hungry and I'm sad [ __ ] you probably
always have it has it has anyone
watching has anyone seen re-creators
this recreator this meeting tonight I
saw the first episode of that like just
today what do you think I'm sorry it's
like I'm because like I kind of like
knew what it was going to be about I was
like oh it's like gonna be the most meta
anime ever created like it's so like it
matter it's like it's so bit like it
makes metal look metal like it's like oh
let's make an anime
where the characters know that they're
in an area and they have to go back into
said anime but let's show that by
showing you an anime about that and it's
like the things we dislike trends in
anime now where's like everyone's trying
to out met each other and then really I
then read and then recreated comes along
is like you guys you guys have seen
nothing yet as like yeah so true it's
like so like it's like light normal
characters and video game characters
being brought into the real world I'm
like they know that they are white novel
and video game characters it's really
[ __ ] it's it's really [ __ ] weird
but it is you're gonna see how like
characters meet their creator euro she
hates you yeah yeah yeah but like it was
merely for cool it's super cool I'm like
the action which was which la drew me in
initially because like I didn't know
what it was like that man
yes Rica which I really hope that I end
up in the same vein as al no zeros man
still worth the right if the only have
fun right it'll be a fun ride which is
like it'll be either great or but it
will just be like so bad that it is just
entertaining to watch which is why I'm
what's going to have 22 episodes us yeah
exactly
which is like every time I see an anime
now that's over 12 episodes I'm just
replication my wage at the pet iPad to
sweat off my head dude I'm like are we
back with the bubbles very radically
checks watch are we back in the golden I
start like my just likes to kicks in and
I'm like is that one really there into
the second digit on the right doesn't 17
or 2007 where are we why it's like you
know like you know there must be a big
deal when like every studio now has like
commitment issues I'm sorry when once
you do just actually like actually
commits enough to say hey from the
get-go
we're gonna make this too cool you're
like oh sure this is the real [ __ ]
deal now I seriously make it to court
I'm just like oh this is serious
well [ __ ] I'm like there's so much money
in this this has to work or it's going
this has to
good exactly I mean like did I kill I
remember I found out a little bit like a
dame yet it's gonna it's to court and I
was like are you what that was Alesi
yeah 25 episodes like yeah and I'm like
damn and then I did and I met the floor
thing like ah [ __ ]
nobody's going to watch it it was a with
little witch academia like I was
thinking man like the industry saying we
are the that they're like losing money
losing money and then they have some low
budgets in order to make like Vienna may
longer but then you've got little witch
academia whose entire budget was off of
Kickstarter what was something well it
was like the second movie was like a
movie and that a lot funding because
that which was enchanted paradise uh
maybe they didn't use all their funding
there they could use Kickstarter fund me
yeah I actually oddly enough I just got
my under the dog blu-ray in like a
masochist what a disappointment what it
was and I got it in and I just have it
I'm going to keep it as a reminded that
whatever but to spend money i I want to
hold the case like and then I'll decide
it's also like sixty dollars in for that
and it look like it was it I feel like a
disappointed father this is like no I
really know what is your more times you
just this is this is what this is what I
get
I look so cool do they used to Emma for
isn't [ __ ] like I was awesome and then
you're like what's happening it wasn't
even like oh no this is relevant I was
like wow disappointment hollered on my
dreams yes you know there's this anime
that just came out the season I actually
wanted you guys like input on do all the
POV anime coming out cuz roommate just
got oh I think I think I know which is
it the one where your is I think you're
a go and you you go into like a harem do
you go into a harem of guys is that it
yeah each yeah each episodes like two to
five minutes yeah you spend it with like
a different guy it's like the one that's
like if they grabbed a visual novel and
just like directly turned it into an
eight if they directed your own visual
yeah but by the way gene gene can you
you only need to get on this mic okay
what's the call
room Nitra heard of it but reminds me a
lot of pillow boy oh yeah Wow I'm
getting myself the same people I believe
yeah a pro doesn't make a lot of sense
well here's the thing about that studio
there they're always making POVs they
made Anatole X they made pillow boys
they did one room now they did roommate
they're all POVs it's the same concept
and I don't know who the hell's funding
any of this for them to make for
different anime having to do with POV I
guess it's easy if their episodes are
only like five minutes long they don't
have too much uh I got [ __ ] into it so
they're able to just spit out about this
I guess someone's having this one in the
background like because because they do
for the obviously both guys and girls
now yes as I added a lot to my watchlist
down G we're on it [ __ ] Oh still last
on the list oh my god we thought I'll
block it out after the top right now I'm
probably going to make a video just of
me interacting or just maybe even not
interacting with those guys like when
you watch this gene like you're going to
feel like you're watching Dora the
Explorer when she asks you about you
don't know what's creepier like you
responding are you just sitting there
not saying anything you know what I
might like that it might bring me back
that's how I saw when I watch pillow
boys man because I was like so apathetic
about Emily oh yeah give any more shits
about this anime that was that was
pretty messed up when they get you to
interact with a five-year-old boy and
they give you a bio before the episode
even started and with the woman my
battles yeah I mean what's a
five-year-old boy
they gave his name and his age I think
it was like ten years old and the
description was hot five year old okay
thankfully Japan this is the future of
animation anyway thank you know we got
those wings we got those hot monks dude
I was like let's go go man that one dude
I was like are you really laughing wait
why are you doing this there's okay so
there's I think it's so what is it it's
the what it's you it has your real name
for something night oh no no no I got
the list here I know I know what you're
talking about when I saw that monk I was
like the old when I saw that monk I was
like whoa misty got his owner
yeah sounds like a legit looks like if
misty was like in an anime we use like
the endless I got a spray can to add
like some stubble it would be misty here
yeah yeah so do Paul Nagi waters
Shaquille Kuno yo Tony yeah I know why
aka Bolger oh [ __ ] I think I know what
you think I saw the [ __ ] cover for
this and it was a digital yeah welcome
yeah it's the world game really really
dude and I was like I do I can get
behind this I've been like proximity
that we need reverse edgy for years now
yeah wait so did you watch it yeah of
course dear I've ran out how was it dude
it was like Bobby it's pretty it's
pretty fast everything that I was pretty
because like the loss because like the
lots reverse Hara my soul was a [ __ ]
psycho brothers conflict holy [ __ ] Wow
which is just like oh it's just a flight
at the end of it I was like what am I
doing with my life I think it's
important to note that it's it is five
minutes it's one of the shorter things
like one of those really short TV shorts
but it okay so it's super low commitment
yeah and because brother complex was
like 12 like full 20 minutes oh no way
that's that is a commitment for reverse
harem yeah because I mean and because
it's so short the commitments really
love so it's always were just trying the
same reason that like God all those
years ago I was like man people might be
good and I was like oh my god I've
completely for God I had so much
expectation for that because I love the
munger of that yes so it's like like why
[Music]
you know I guess that works that it's so
short like you could literally just like
go take a [ __ ] and watch that show while
you're at it yeah pretty much
it's so mobile he can share for much
longer
you watch the show um it's a visual
laxative if you're constantly oh my god
yeah um hold on I'll give it go watch an
episode of pupil yeah you baby poop oh
very oh my god oh honey
laughter take it boy
you know what anime is like really big
here in Japan right now it's the season
I've been meaning to see it as what is
this called a like oh she took Jill she
heyn heyn at what this one the Royal
tutor
oh the Royal part of that for the first
episode of that yeah III don't know
anything about this and there's only six
episodes right now but I've been seeing
a lot of this in Japan yeah I mean I
guess it's like it's like the opposite
of like you know the whole mo a thing
with cute girls doing cute things where
apparently they realize that girls want
to see classy boys doing farty thing is
hot in a calm way you know that that's
that's that's the trend for for that and
for that kind of thing I mean I look
like a lot their shows they likely
exactly follows the vein of something
like Ouran High School Host Club or
black mana or that kind of thing
not that anything's wrong or high school
know that anything is wrong with I'm
just saying it just fits in that
category yeah yeah um what I do want to
talk about though is boruto which dude
and yeah quite a bit yeah I mean I'm not
gonna lie you know me and you Holden um
we we followed Naruto's so thick and
thin and we were just like we held the
funeral like we held the funeral for
Naruto we were just like you know thank
you for giving us our childhood
everything but we're just we're just
ready to let you go now and then boruto
comes away
yeah we're just like dude we buried you
to stay there I think it's it's super
because it's like I I do not believe it
can maintain this level of quality I
don't even like because it's like I
don't know MIT it feels just like the
first time you watch nerds I know like
it captures the essence uper well it's
so good at edges it's because the thing
is it feels it feels fresh at the same
time but it feels familiar it has this
perfect balance where you feel like
you're very experienced narrator again
except you're not in a sense and it is
it just really surprised me because the
[ __ ] fourth mineral water are just
[ __ ] killed the franchise for me and
I thought that nothing else to come that
could ever entertain me again
and Barroso not only like the series but
the movies as well which i think is the
best thing the franchise has done for a
very very long time is definitely worth
the watch for any Naruto fans or like
even like any new fans just getting into
anime and one of me like hey what was
this Naruto [ __ ] that all these old guys
were talking about because yeah we're
pretty old now
I'm not even not going to mention that
so yeah it's it's just a great [ __ ] a
stouter treatment so would you say that
boruto do you think that they need to
watch Naruto before boruto or do you
think it's like that fresh because I'll
be honest I didn't keep up with Naruto
like until early she cuz you don't have
to when RS you don't have a hard time
it's that's like that it never it never
flashes back to the original show at all
it doesn't even okay reference the other
show yeah the cool thing about having
known it is that you see a lot of
familiar things you're like I know these
side characters because they were side
characters for 10 years
let's look back in my day these guys
watch the Chunin exams like a lot of
people are the same as a lot of people
have grown up and they're different yeah
when a lot of it feels super familiar
because you're like oh I've spent years
in the Conan but if you haven't noted at
all
it still feels kind of like you know
this is just this guy doing stuff and
you can pass off people plugger if they
made a Pokemon series pull one would it
wouldn't change it's like Ash had a kid
or something right right but if you knew
who Ash was and everything you might
care more what the heat bait okay all
the side characters are relegated to a
position of like the same kind of
position you'd put somebody in a normal
shown in series like all might God I
think of all my Taz like Naruto now they
kind of filled the same role the Naruto
is not like deku anymore yeah kind of
just this you know this guy with his
smiles at grinning it is like his fist
on his hips like hey son what's up and
it's just like that's so that's a crazy
dad right there and yeah but he's just
the support gunboat it's all cut it is
it done in a way where it's making
tribute to those I grew up with Naruto
but also like
introducing yeah cuz like the Forester
is actually nothing like Naruto which is
what feels fresh it's like refresh he he
has a very different he's a very
different character from Naruto which is
not stupid
yeah which is it's not just the same
thing all over again which is what makes
you feel fresh but we get to see unlike
all these characters we grew up with
playing a kind of like a more mature
role which is really surprising because
Naruto is actually a very shitty dad no
he's a terrible with that and it's just
like I'm so interesting that Sasuke is a
much better dad and Naruto with me it's
just like what that's a good not
expected kinda like the comparison
between a like Gohan and Goku right like
how Gohan is much more reserved and
level-headed and like a kind person
whereas Goku just like this selfless
alien who wants to be Jesus yeah exactly
and it's like it's really cool because
you get to see the difference between
parents and kids which is like real life
but like it's it's super different then
you would you'd expect like because he's
enough he's not stupid like I can't say
enough like Naruto
was this stupid kid boruto just isn't an
idiot and it's shocking because he looks
like Naruto and so I'm like he's going
to do stupid stuff now and he just
doesn't yeah rushing yeah um but yeah
that's I think that's pretty much
everything I wanted to cover from this
season unless there's anything else you
guys you guys have seen or want to talk
about man we talked about a lot and then
we talked about quite a yeah I mean
oh the only thing I want to mention is
seven mortal sins watch it okay oh yeah
I got my own PI defenders
I know I got you oh my god
all right well I think that's I think
that's a good place to stop it I've been
a hell of a lot of fun leave it up at
the elk I yeah [ __ ] I said I said so
like just to bring it all back my final
thoughts are watch arrow manga sensei
and just join me in this track so please
join me in the trash bag there's plenty
of [ __ ] room genes in here as well
yes no actually it's a dumpster truck
guard
right yeah we hid in the landfill boy
yeah when we're lucky just you were
getting the stump to talk with us and
we're heading to the landfill [ __ ] it
buddy action Odie join in oh we're here
um but yeah thank you all for joining me
today it's in yeah no problem thanks
grab a nice man all right three
different time zones this was this was a
bugger to I get together but I mean I'm
happy it finally happened
yeah since she came to me two weeks ago
Jean and just like I want to look
whatever manga sensei okay let's wait a
bit yeah because brothers in public and
Series play to fire me did it I've been
suffering oh I don't like [ __ ] Jessica
I make video about it I can't wait okay
so with me today has been holding from
holding reviews yeah all [ __ ] is it
holding reviews again closing yeah
whatever run anything she's told guests
no I guess now because your sky still
holding reviews because you never yeah
well let's go see how often a yeah
thanks to Anne we do if you guys want to
hang out this ever you can go check out
the anime no you may also see discord
with it oh yeah yeah we are holding has
well we all have a kind of discord
community which we I guess we can shout
out now so holdings in there way more
than me because I'm isn't doing
animation once yeah yeah so join if you
want link for that will be in the
description um also we have Jean from
anime appraisal all right it was a
pleasure guys
thanks for having me and until next time
we have Joey the anime man from the Ala
Moana
the engineer from the anime me
yeah thanks for having us yeah yeah we
have our own podcast show oh yeah the
Enfield are you gonna advertise oh God
go ahead I just did that - you thought
we were all like channel you know Jeff
to you special like everything we can
which are you know yeah go to book
Walker by the way use coupon code you go
thank you very much yeah yeah yeah
crunchyroll.com slash any women with
everybody check it out and
I'm archaea from dearest oculomotor feet
here and it just looks so well rocky
from dearest rocky from I just want to
call you oculus akihabeera thank you
very much have a good day
oh I feel like so relieved now because
like I've wanted to talk about these
show some [ __ ] ages so like I
literally just feel like I've just
orgasms all this out
Vidia pretty I feel great oh yeah my
ovaries birth did long ago